foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Pods at
Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am your
host today Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality and best-selling author
taking your calls all across America
it's a free call anywhere in the country
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five and I figured in this hour I
want to ask all of our callers that call
in
one pain point when it comes to buying
food so with inflation and everything
going on I feel like the number one
question I get when I'm out or on social
media is around saving money when it
comes to food so whether it's grocery
shopping or out to eat so we're gonna
play that little game with all the
callers this hour so first up we have
Ricky in Phoenix up first so hey Ricky
welcome to the show
hi uh thank you so much for taking my
call absolutely okay so I just kind of
threw this curveball on you Ricky do you
have a great money saving hack when it
comes to food before we get to your
question
um gosh well I'm actually we're really
really blessed
um we are on
um yeah EBT get food stamps right now so
that's kind of how what we're using to
supplement oh yeah being able to serve
our food every month and it's um I know
obviously it's not like a long-term
solution but in the meantime it's just
really been able to help us and it's
been such a blessing yeah well that's
great and especially for people if they
have a change of season or something for
that's yeah something to look for to
kind of be that bridge and their stage
of life that's so great okay that's so
perfect Ricky thanks so much all right
what's your question today okay yeah so
just a little bit of background um so my
husband and myself and my two children
we are living at home with my dad right
now
um we do hate we do pay him rent
um it's very reasonable
um but other than that I feel like we
don't have like a ton of huge expenses
um and so my husband he actually just
received an injury settlement check in
the amount of seventy five thousand
dollars oh wow is he okay yeah yeah uh
yes yeah so he's he's okay now and it's
fine I'm so sorry
um you know has a good standard of life
he still has like pain but you know for
the most part
um he yeah he is good okay good
um yeah and so so for with that I mean
we you know we're living with my dad and
really our goal is we would love to be
able to buy our own home
um but just like in Phoenix and where
we're looking with the house prices even
if we put like a 20 down payment yeah we
can't even afford a mortgage like a
30-year mortgage let alone a 15-year
fixed mortgage on my husband's income
what it is right now
um and it just feels you know really
discouraging and I know a lot of people
feel that way right now but
um and it just the thought of having to
save you know another 50 175 Grand you
know whatever it needs to be to get that
mortgage sure 25 of our take-home pay it
just feels like right what do you guys
make a year
so he last year he grossed um forty
eight thousand dollars and then this
year he's projected to make closer to 55
000. 55 000 okay
okay and you guys are one you're living
with your dad you're paying rent but you
guys really want to do be out on your
own do you have kids yes we do yeah we
have two we have that well we have a
baby he's turning one
um almost three-year-old okay um two
boys okay um and so I guess my question
is if if it would be a good idea for us
to put money into dividing my dad's
house to make it like a more sustainable
living situation long term and kind of
plan to just stay here for the remainder
of my dad's wife or and then if that's
not a good idea kind of um
secondly where should we park that money
in the meantime we currently we just
have it in our money market account at
our local bank yeah we're I'm just
wondering if maybe there's something
that is like more of like a short-term
investment activity or something like
that that would be better yeah it's a
great it's a great question and I know
so many people want to be homeowners I
mean I feel like this is such a it's the
American dream right and we talk about
it a lot on this show but that but the
point is that math has to work for you
guys Ricky and with the income that you
guys have which is fine I want you to
have a house not only that you can save
up the down payment for but that you
guys can sustain that this that the
mortgage won't be you know a huge part
of your take-home pay that it's going to
be something that you guys actually see
as a blessing and it doesn't end up
being a curse and a burden and so you
have to be able to look at the price
points of your income and that's that's
the starting point and I think some
people jump to the house first and
they're like hey what's the kind of
house we want let's figure out how to
make our life work with that house where
sometimes that's backwards you guys have
to look at your income and say okay
we're making 50 thousand dollars a year
what can we afford with that income and
letting that be the springboard to the
math which means it may not be a huge
house it may not even be a single family
home maybe it's a town home or maybe
it's a condo for a bit but I think
getting in the market is a great goal
for you guys are do you guys have
Consumer Debt
so no we had like a really small amount
of kind of like non-traditional debt
that my husband actually he we went to
pay it yesterday and then there was an
issue so he's actually going to pay that
today and that was like a little under
ten thousand dollars okay and so and
that's it and then do you guys have any
other savings besides um we had about
ten thousand dollars in savings as well
that we had
um and then we and we both have super
cars and we don't like use credit cards
really
um we just had a couple ones that we
were using to kind of build our credit
but we don't keep a balance it's just
like we use this repair internet you
know and that's it okay
well what I would recommend Ricky is I
feel like you guys it's a it's you're
you're kind of dabbling in one area you
have this money over here all of it and
I think getting everything together and
looking at a holistic picture is going
to help you guys so I want you to stay
on the line and Arsenal pick up and I
want you guys to go through Financial
Peace University and your husband
together because what it's going to help
you do is not only see hey our
day-to-day life like even you saying
yeah we have credit cards but we pay you
know bills with those and we pay it off
every month like even having these lines
in the Sands when it comes to your money
and the way you view your money is going
to be so helpful and so being able to
get debt completely out of your life
having that emergency fund which is that
ten thousand dollars which is great and
then saying okay beyond that we want to
save up for a down payment on a home and
that can be your next goal and I think
that it can be great it may not be the
house that you want to live in forever
but I do think that's something that you
guys can start to work towards and with
the money that you have the 75 000 from
his claim yeah I would put it in a high
yield savings account or a money market
account if you guys know in the next
probably five years we're going to be
buying something but I think that being
your next big goal is great but again
Ricky I would encourage you guys to work
around what you make though don't and
it's gonna it might be discouraging you
might be like gosh that is not the kind
of house that we thought we'd have or
that we wanted yeah but I want you guys
to get into this home again it may not
be the home that you wanted but at least
it's home ownership and it's what you
guys want and it's reasonable it's a
reasonable percentage of your take-home
pay because that's going to be the
biggest that's gonna be the biggest
boundary you're gonna have to set in
your in your mind and in your heart and
expectations when you go in and start
shopping for a home
yeah we were actually we were almost we
were in escrow to buy a house and then
we ended up backing out of the sale
because it was going to be I mean it
wasn't going to be anything it's like
the Ramsay principles I listen to you
guys yeah the podcast literally every
single day when I drive and so we just
actually ended up backing out of that
sale which is we were kind of wondering
about putting money into my dad's house
to make it you know to devise the house
yeah and you can do that I mean you know
depending on the health of your of your
dad I would hate to like just wait
around you know to to be a homeowner
with his passing I think you guys as a
family
can actually have a goal in place and
actually start working where I get your
income up uh for your husband and do
what he cans if that means even shifting
a little bit of career choices but to be
able to bring in some of that extra
money and that you guys really do
believe and and do your own thing and
then when he does pass if the house is
in the will and all that you can talk
about that further but I think for now
that's a goal for you and your family so
thanks Ricky this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show and if
you guys enjoy this show and you're a
listener on the regular whether it's on
podcast or radio or YouTube please
consider sharing it I think this is one
of the best ways for people to learn
about it and hopefully take control of
their money and and find some peace when
it comes to their life whether that's in
their relationships their career their
marriage their friendships and also with
their money so again leave a review
share the show rate the show all of it
it really is helpful in the algorithm of
of life and media it is so so helpful
and I and I find always for me whenever
someone recommends a podcast or a book
from and it's a friend I'm usually up to
actually do it I'm like oh yeah I want
to listen to that so your friends and
family will listen to you people I
promise so share share uh the Ramsay
show with them so that hopefully again
they can have some peace when it comes
to their money all right up next we have
Deborah in Orlando hey Debra welcome to
the show
hi Rachel good to be here yes well
thanks for calling okay so I I threw
this curveball in the first segment uh
to ask all the callers do you have any
money saving hacks when it comes to food
because this is the that's the one
budget Buster for so many people and
it's been affected by inflation so much
do you have any tips
uh so my big one that I've used that's
been a huge money saver for me is I
actually do a neat subscription box oh
yeah I get my meat and because it's I'm
a single mom and it's me and my two and
a half year old we like are it stretches
over like three months and so I'm
getting my money's worth out so smart do
you freeze the stuff that you don't use
obviously yeah and they come like
packaged up into like pound segments so
I can just take like it's fantastic okay
and it's a great and it's a better price
than just going and buying it at the at
the store when you need it yeah for for
me in Florida it absolutely is yes okay
the meat subscription well done Deborah
that's a great tip thanks for sharing
okay so yeah so what's your question for
today
uh so I am in the beginnings of a
surrogacy journey uh and
I'm gonna be getting in extra income
um I'm not sure if I should be
incorporating it into my budget once
because once
it fully starts I'll have set dates of
getting paid or if I should just take it
as like extra commission bonus money and
use it that way okay do you where are
you financially do you have debt do you
have any savings
um I have my starter emergency fund and
I am gazelle intense getting my 12 600
paid off by the end of August twelve
thousand six hundred dollars so great
how much have you paid off so far
uh
the on and off gazelle intensity it's
been I've paid off about thirteen
thousand dollars a year Deborah
well done that's awesome
okay so how much will you be getting for
this what are the payments what's the
schedule and how much money will be with
each payment
so the payments Baseline are right
around thirty five hundred dollars but
there's different segments where like in
month three they're gonna send me extra
money for a maternity wardrobe the last
uh five months if I'm carrying twins I
get an extra like five thousand dollars
so there's a little bit of variation
okay
yeah yeah yeah so will you know ahead of
time though how much it will be
yeah the only
unsure factors is if like I go on bed
rest and they'll cover lost wages I
won't know that until I go on yeah yeah
totally totally no that's great so yeah
so I would honestly see this more as a
bonus uh because your current job that
you're in you're able to live off of
that correct your current income yeah I
actually yeah I just got full time and I
doubled my income so I did my expense
report and I'm able to pull an extra
like three thousand dollars to pay
towards debt that's awesome okay so I
would just look at this yes it's going
to be technically income but I would
throw it at your baby step so I would
just see this as like a bonus every
three months and use it to attack your
debt or to save up for your uh three to
six months of expenses for your
emergency fund
okay that's wonderful how did you get
into this into this journey what was the
motivation for you
um
being someone who's kind of always been
a slave to debt I've just I've never had
the ability to give financially to help
other people and it's something God put
on my heart that was like hey
you could give your body you really
enjoyed being pregnant you could help
another family yeah so I was like yeah
let's do that yeah and that's it that's
a gift for people I know people that
have gone through that Journey um before
so you definitely are offering something
really
um wonderful to a family so that's
that's awesome Deborah so yeah again I
would just use that extra money from
those payments and throw it at your baby
steps and continue it on so um I pray
that it all goes well and health for you
and the future baby and everything so
that's great Deborah thanks for calling
all right up next we have Hudson in
Portland hey Hudson welcome to the show
hi glad to be on here thanks okay I'm
gonna throw my question at you that I
asked Debra earlier do you have any do
you have any grocery savings hacks or
food saving hacks Hudson to save some
money during this time
um so it's kind of kind of obvious
um but buying in bulk is what uh my
family has always done
um is it and then the important thing
about it though is like you know you run
into Costco or Sam's Club or something
and you see you know uh bulk bulk
amounts of uh things about Parish easy
you got to make sure you're buying bulk
for your household size so it might be
something to get you know five loaves of
bread for you know like how however much
bread costs now but for a really good
price but then it's like oh you only got
you know four people in the house not
running through five who loves to bread
every week
yeah for sure but buying in bulk that is
when you can look at the price per ounce
and all that especially the stuff that
doesn't go bad uh I'm a huge fan of that
that's so good okay awesome so what's
your what's your question today
so my question today is I'm about to my
wife and I are about to pay off our our
last piece of credit card debt we only
have about 750 left on that congrats
um and then I've got a uh some student
loan debt that's about two thousand five
hundred dollars and then we have a uh
vehicle loan for 32k
um and so basically what I'm wondering
is with student loan uh interest rates
still being Frozen right now should we
focus on paying off the the truck as
fast as possible or should we or should
I go ahead and just get my student loans
done out of the way yeah I would go and
get your student loans out of the way
because what we found with debt payoff
is actually less about interest rate and
math and it's more about Behavior I mean
you guys you're I can hear your
excitement and your voice now of like oh
my gosh we only have 750 left to pay on
this credit card
and there's just something about the
momentum and the progress that you
create in life that you're like oh I
it's amazing the momentum that happens
when you just don't have all these other
payments going out so financially it's
that snowball effect of having more and
more money to throw at the car because
that is going to be your largest debt so
teaching people to pay off the smallest
debt first regardless of the interest
rate is the way we've seen it be most
effective so honestly I would for sure
pay off that credit card that 750 knock
out that student loan get it paid off
and it's just going to feel better
you're going to feel this weight really
lifted off of even having that amount of
debt paid off and then I would go after
the truck so uh for the truck how much
do you guys make a year
um so combined it's uh roughly uh if I
did my math right 70k a year okay
and does your wife have a car
uh no she does not okay so you guys are
one a one car family
right okay because you're kind of right
at that cusp we always say if you can't
pay off the car in 12 to 18 months
you may have just too much car so I want
you guys to kind of run the math out and
make sure that you guys are able to to
cut your lifestyle in order to pay this
off but if you feel like you're going to
be having this for three more years it's
it's honestly not not worth it uh to
keep the truck so you may want to look
at even selling it and
our rule of thumb too
is not to have anything with motors and
wheels that's over 50 percent of your
take-home pay per year your income and
so you're kind of bumping up a little
bit against that with this truck so just
a couple things to think about I think
um if you guys can knock it out and do
some side hustles and get rid of this
truck quickly uh then you can keep it
but if it feels overwhelming and it
feels like a lot you would you might
consider selling it
right and yeah that's uh that's why I
was doing a ton of research before you
know getting myself into this into this
mess I'm like am I going to am I going
to feel overwhelmed or you know
uncomfortable and living super paycheck
to paycheck but uh we're still able to
to feed and house ourselves uh with uh
even with the the truck payment on here
um I have been selling like crazy though
um that until you get that credit card
knocked down selling some other just
stuff around the house that I don't need
yeah that's awesome
that's what's really uh helped me you
know close out credit card debt that's
great Hudson well you guys are on the
journey you're on it so yep hit that
student loan next after the credit card
and then start working to pay off the
truck uh but if it just gets really
annoying and you're like man we just
want to be debt free faster you can
always sell the truck buy buy a clunker
as we say and then go back and save and
pay cash later this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour because
most of our team is out of town so all
of the other Ramsay personalities that
you hear on this show including Dave
Ramsey himself they are all out most of
them are in Southern California Anaheim
to do our Building Wealth event so we
travel all the all over the country
doing uh different events depending on
the season in this season we've been
doing Building Wealth so we were in
Indianapolis and Austin Salt Lake City
and now the team is in Anaheim so I
pulled some strings texted a few people
that I know and I thought how fun would
it be for some of them to call in I
tried to convince Dave so we'll see if
that ends up happening in the show to
call in and tell us how it's going on
the road and just to talk about things
that are going on in our economy so I I
this is like a first time I think but we
got we got Kenneth Coleman oh ken
Coleman on the line hey Ken
hey Rachel how are you I'm doing well
you're two hours behind so did you are
you did you sleep in
no as a matter of fact uh the old body
clock won
I wish I wish I could have slept in but
I think it was about 5 30 in the morning
uh my body was like let's go let's go
because I was sleeping in central time
but I got to tell you I'm in my room
here in Anaheim and I'm overlooking
Disney oh no way y'all's hotel is right
by Disneyland well that's where we are
uh so anyway fun times and we miss you
out here for sure I know I'm holding it
down here in Nashville in the studio all
by my lonesome but that's fine you're
doing great so y'all are excited about
Building Wealth tonight you all have how
many probably 2 000 people out there
yeah yeah it's gonna be over 2 000
people packed out and uh it's gonna be a
lot of fun always great to be out on the
road and meet people and and uh you know
help them and give them hope that
despite the uncertainty of our economy
that they can control their life so
always a great time so good well the
uncertainty of the economy it's it's
everywhere Ken I feel like I turn on the
news or thing you know the app on my
phone comes up and the word recession is
happening that like the GDP dropped
again inflation is still all over the
place so what are things that you're
seeing because you talk to people all
the time about being in a career that
that they love and that they're really
good at and kind of meeting all those
passions together but the job market is
affected by things going on right now in
the economy too
what was your questions so let's talk
about your money and that's what we're
about on the ranch show and what it uh
means to your job when you've got a
potential recession looming so as you
said GDP dropped uh for a third straight
month and we are now seeing inflation
starting to tick back up a little bit
and now what the big concern is is with
the FED meeting tomorrow as we speak
most people believe they're going to do
a 10th consecutive rate hike a quarter
point and everybody's kind of watching
to see will this be the end or at least
a pause for rate hikes now
Gerald Powell the Fed chair has said
Rachel that part of the strategy of
raising interest rates is they want to
see the employment Market soften and
what that means is unemployment rate
goes up we're still at 3.5 percent but
the latest job data came out this week
that we saw Less jobs open so we saw
contraction companies aren't open as
many jobs now here's where that puts us
that does lean us toward a recession
most people think in the third or fourth
quarter nobody knows how big it will be
but this is what it means to you the
person out there is going what about my
job and my income and winning with money
when you see recession reports start to
pop up more and more and I think you'll
see that in the next month to two months
you will start to see layoffs and you
could see the unemployment rate jump and
so if that and that's because companies
are are cutting where they can
continue we don't know how bad it's
going to be that's right and so it's
almost like when we in our own personal
budgets when we sense that there's going
to be more expenses what do we do we
hopefully tighten down everything and
that's the advice here today we don't
know how bad the recession is going to
be we don't know when it is going to be
but what we know is is that it can be
recession-proof and you certainly
understand that we've got to cut our
unnecessary expenses yeah we've got to
keep dropping debt as fast as we can and
then we've got to increase our income
and here's the good news Rachel we are
in a very good
part-time job side hustle economy
freelance economy and I would be making
as much money as possible uh saving if
you're out of debt or killing debt
reducing those household expenses so
that if you are laid off you've got a
plan and that's the key I want people to
understand that you don't have to be
victim to a recession into your company
laying you off you can get ahead of this
and be ready yeah because I mean can I
was in the lobby earlier and there was a
guy and he said he paid off almost a
hundred thousand dollars delivering
pizzas like it's it's that I mean it's
it's proof that there is availability to
go and make money doing things that are
not just your typical nine to five job
that people think you know when they
hear the word career they may have this
just like stereotype in their head of
yeah that's going to an office and it's
nine to five uh but the world we live in
now I mean it's it it's so different
it's like there are so many things you
can even just piece together if you
needed to for a season and actually make
great income and I think that's what's
encouraging to people is you know it
used to be like oh yeah well if you did
a certain level of job you're not going
to make much but that's kind of just
exploded I feel like in the sense of
it's amazing what people are paying what
employers are paying employees uh for
even these side hustles well you're
absolutely right I'll give you four
quick ones so I just pulled up some
information from all the different job
sites out there and I just did an
aggregate okay and so let's talk about
personal driving now these are in areas
where if you live in a wealthy area and
a metropolitan area even if you're in
the suburbs people are looking for
personal drivers okay this isn't this
isn't delivering pizza this is driving
delivering food uh and or driving
errands and things like that for people
that are wealthy you're looking at about
twenty dollars per hour average nannies
right now and babysitting you know this
all-time highs an average salary across
the country of about twenty dollars an
hour in some form of meaning freelance
work just take a skill that you have
right now in your current job can you
offer yourself online after hours as a
freelancer the average freelancer salary
right now 22 dollars an hour and then
one more tutors you can't believe how
online tutoring has exploded because you
can tutor anywhere the average tutor
right now in the country is making about
20 four dollars per hour so those are
examples of what you just brought up
that in any economy certain or uncertain
if you are willing to put in the work
you can stack money up to again get rid
of get to save and be Recession Proof
that's good all up to you yes it's so
good Ken and kind of talk to the person
that may feel hesitant at times because
I feel like if you're used to a certain
path when it comes to your career
especially before coven and everything
is shifted so whether you've shifted
jobs or you've lost your job if you're
going to be somebody that's going to be
affected by this even in the third and
fourth quarter there's no job that's
beneath you and you're you're really
great at kind of hitting this right on
Ken because of how important it is that
it's like put your ego aside like
there's going to be seasons of life that
you just need to do what you what you
need to do to get that margin and to get
that peace of mind yeah it's a really
good point it does not matter what the
job is what matters are the results of
the job and if you were making extra
money to put you and your family in
better financial situation to Achieve
Financial Peace to be recession-proof to
take care of very important unforeseen
medical expenses work is worthy and it
doesn't matter what you look like smell
like what matters is that you're making
money for the important things in your
life all work is Honorable and I think
it's a very important point and no one
else cares everybody else got their own
problems but if you are out there doing
what it takes to get out of debt to to
create that emergency fund that full of
Mercy fund to create so much peace in
your life to take care of some
unforeseen medical expenses to make a
move for your child when they need maybe
some special help in school or whatever
that is what you're focused on the
result of the work not the work itself
yes that's so good and not to let words
like recession and these scary headlines
that could be everywhere and could
actually paralyze people freak people
out and they make bad decisions because
of this fear to actually focus on what's
going on in your home and even the
examples you just gave of you know
actual needs that families have and so
focusing on you and your household is so
key during times that feel all over the
place and that fear can take over so Ken
thanks for calling in all the way from
California I wish you guys the best at
the event tonight if you're in Anaheim
there might still be some tickets that
might be sold out but you can check
ramseysolutions.com and the team's over
in Anaheim California for our Building
Wealth event tonight this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show we just
got off the phone with Ken Coleman one
of our Ramsay personalities that's out
in California doing our Building Wealth
event and if you guys love the stuff
that he talks about on the Ken Coleman
show or read his books he's actually
going to be in Chicago Atlanta and
Dallas in May doing the career
breakthrough events and these are
smaller events so tickets are limited so
make sure to go to ramseysolutions.com
events to uh if you're in that City or
want to travel to one of those cities
and to listen to Ken because he has some
so much great stuff to say when it comes
to your passions and your career
so people are either naturally a spender
or a saver and I'm definitely a spender
so having any cash on hand is something
that I love that I can use to you know
go out to eat buy something shop that's
one reason I'm so excited to announce
are Ramsay cash giveaway it is back so
this is your chance to win up to 500 to
3 000 which is our grand prize and it's
really easy to enter all you have to do
is go to ramseysolutions.com giveaway
and you can increase your chances of
winning by entering every single day no
purchase necessary but you must be 18 or
older to win and we're not stopping
there if you love a good sale we have
our ten dollar sale going on it's kind
of the infamous Ramsay solution sale
where a lot of our products over 30
products are only ten dollars this is
everything from questions for humans uh
Dr John deloney's products some of his
books Dave Ramsey's newest best-selling
book baby steps millionaires my book
know yourself know your money and even
more so again 30 items there in the
Ramsey solutions store online are just
ten dollars and a lot of people buy the
stuff for themselves they buy it for
people to give away but go to
ramseysolutions.com
and check out the 10 sale today
all right it is a free call anywhere in
the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and up next we
have Nathan in Indianapolis hey Nathan
welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me on taking my
call absolutely okay so before we get to
your question we've been asking people
this hour if they have any
tips when it comes to saving money on
food so whether that's groceries or
going out to eat because with inflation
and food on the rise it's always the
biggest budget Buster category so I'm
kind of putting you on the spot Nathan
but do you have any tips when it comes
to saving for food
100 do and that is shop at Aldi for
everything because Aldi is the greatest
store in the history of the world
um for people trying to save money uh
and the food is still great quality so
yes that's a Shameless plug no I love it
you know it's funny on my show the
Rachel Cruz show that's one of the
places I always tell people to go I'm
like go to ALDI and because you do you
save so much on your grocery bill to the
point that people like are you sponsored
by Aldi I was like nope but I should be
because I promote it all the time so we
are on the Saveway wavelength there
Nathan that's great great tip all right
so what's your what's your question
today
well my question is in relation so my
wife and I we have two debts left
um we have a car loan that is nine
thousand five hundred dollars uh
interest rate of 6.99 at the fixed rate
that's important to the second part of
this question our other debt is
um uh my wife's student loan which we
have twenty two thousand five hundred
dollars left on but it is on a variable
interest rate which is currently at
14.75 percent and has been climbing at
about point two five percent a month and
I know I'm supposed to be focused on
that smaller one but watching the
interest rate and therefore the monthly
payment go higher every month on the
other one is really starting to
um eat at me a little bit and so I was
curious if there are like is
consolidation a possibility to get uh
just a fixed interest rate with the two
of these even though my name is not on
my wife's student Alone
um just so we can uh keep because it
feels like we're just working against
ourselves with that interest rate going
up meaning the payment going up and we
don't yeah is it a private loan
it is it's a private loan through a
Sallie Mae yeah okay
um and we only our salary is uh I'm a
youth pastor we make forty eight
thousand dollars a year and so when
those payments go up we start to notice
it and lose some of that extra money
that we want to throw uh at the car debt
um and so we tried to refinance
um her student loan but she has uh a
couple of marks of delinquency on her
credit due to some accounts that her
mother opened without her knowledge back
oh my gosh senior in high school
um
so I I believe those
should drop off uh sometime this year
but
um have you guys contacted the creditors
about that because I mean that's
basically like a level of identity theft
of her mom doing that right so we have
but the the issue is that
um uh my wife she received like so one
of them was for like a computer one of
them was for some items that are like
some clothing items that her mom gave to
her so because she received like benefit
from it then they um yeah they said that
there wasn't much we could do as far as
disputing it and it's obviously there's
a there's a whole tense relationship
there component as well right so I was
just wondering what our options are to
lower that interest rate while we
focused on the car
um like is consolidation even possible
in this situation or what you would what
your advice would be yeah it's a great
question because usually with debt
consolidation for majority of people we
kind of we shy against it because it
because what happens is it's like you
know you're not going to be able to uh
change your behavior because people are
they work at the math issue right so but
for you guys the one type of debt we do
say to consolidate that we're okay with
is actually student loans because you're
more than likely not going to go back
into student loan debt right so the the
issue of fixing the behavior is a big
part of winning with money long term and
debt consolidation ends up just trying
to fix the math of it and not the
behavior but for you guys in this
situation
um it would it would it might actually
be an option to go and look to say okay
if we consolidate these because the
interest rate is completely out of
control and it keeps growing with these
private student loans
um
so you you can again I want to say out
loud though the caution is is that this
isn't going to fix your life right I
mean the idea that you consolidate debt
a lot of people think well that's that's
the fix and that's going to make it okay
but still the hard work and sacrificing
lifestyle taking on an extra job doing
the things you have to do to get above
this debt and pay it off is still at
play so math isn't always the problem
but I but in your situation he said I I
see where math is the problem I mean
that's it's an insane interest rate but
you know even even credit cards like
they're up to this this type of interest
rate too right now with inflation so
um so if you I mean if you if you guys
wanted to it's something you could look
into but the problem is it's not going
to go away this debt is still going to
be there so I still want that intensity
from you and your wife to continue on
um even if it's just kind of shuffling
around interest rates and debt but it
may give you a little bit of breathing
room uh month to month like you're
saying because it continues to go up and
you're saying it's going up like two
percent a month
yeah that's right that's right yeah so I
mean Nathan honestly at this point I
think looking at your income and you
guys saying hey first season what does
it look like to up that income
live on nothing which I mean you guys
are doing I mean you're 48 000 with a
family do you guys have kids
okay yeah so yeah so you're feeling it
your wife doesn't work
correct okay yeah so I mean for this
season Nathan I really I would encourage
you to to look to say we were just
talking about side hustles in the last
segment with with Ken Coleman and what
you can do to get that income up to pay
this off because again you can go I mean
if you get off the call and go and
consolidate you know there's it's not
that's not the wrong thing to do but it
doesn't fix the problem and that's what
ends up happening with debt
consolidation so often is people think
it's the fix and it's not you're the fix
you and your wife are you know you guys
are the ones that are able to fix this
problem not math so so again if it's
something that you want to look into you
can
um but you guys have a you have a you
have a journey ahead of you have you
paid off any debt uh so far besides the
numbers you just gave me
yeah we have paid off about 22
000 uh worth of debt since we got
married oh wow awesome
congratulations that's awesome so you
guys are on this you're on this journey
you know what it feels like to win so
yeah with these last two debts if you
want to do it
um yeah again you can but the secret
sauce is you guys and and what you've
already accomplished so far so I just
want to encourage you on that
um again it's not the easy way out but
if it helps you with the math and the
interest rates right now while things
continue to rise uh you can look into it
but you guys are it the people that get
out of debt and choose to choose this
path they're the ones that end up uh
being the heroes of Their Own Story so
thanks Nathan so much for the call and
thank you America thanks to all the guys
in the booth as we Host this show
because I'm hosting the show solo today
thank you America again triple eight
eight two five five two two five call in
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
it's Rachel Cruz if you love this show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the Ramsay way
just go to ramseysolutions.com today to
sign up for our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
well do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships so I am
Rachel Cruz hosting at this show solo
because most of our team is out in
California at The Building Wealth live
events that they are doing tonight and
so as we were James and I The Producers
were talking about segments of the show
and how to make the show fun we had a
lot of real estate calls yesterday that
were coming in with uh Jade our Ramsey
personality and I were hosting and James
was like man it would be it'd be cool
Rachel if your husband came in and
answered some of these real estate
questions and I thought well
I don't know maybe I'll text and ask him
so I was like babe would you come in and
do an hour of the show and talk about
real estate on the Ramsay show and you
said
sure oh no I said let me think about it
let me think about it so we talked last
night so I wrote them in you guys this
is a first this is a first but
I really didn't want to have this
discussion because we talk about
Building Wealth a lot on this show and
for a lot of people especially our age
and things I see on social media
Instagram Tick Tock all the stuff
investment real estate is something that
people really are interested in and
they're they think it's kind of this get
rich quick and you see these numbers of
these Instagram
influencers or financial people like oh
yeah just go and borrow a bunch here and
get some rental houses and get some
tenants in and just passive income it's
like the easiest thing ever I make so
much money every month doing that and
I'm sitting there always listening
knowing what you go through when it
comes to rentals and real estate because
you have your license your you have a
brokerage you've been doing real estate
for how long
um 10 12 years 10 12 years yeah after
development and having tenants and all
that so yeah I kind of want to actually
uh I actually used to interrupt this
show while Dave was doing it and I'd run
downstairs and Pitch him a deal while he
was on air back in 2012 days yeah so I
it you know it's full circle now so now
I get to deliver all the mistakes and
wisdom that you want to know that's it
that's it okay but just to Bunk the high
level myth that like it's just so easy
all you do is just have a renter and
have passive income and that's it that's
it it's just it's mailbox money yeah no
I think the dream is easy and that's
what everybody gets sold on
um everybody gets sold on
this lifestyle that they see or could
imagine without having to necessarily
work yes and I think there's a
correlation between covid and the kind
of passive income quick money flip uh uh
phase and culture
um because I think it's kind of fed this
we can make life whatever we want it to
be and there doesn't have to be any pain
associated with it yes and as with most
things in life especially with money
there's nothing like that that exists
um unless you win the lottery and that's
a lot of gas station pain
um so it is a uh I think the dream is
easy but actually getting to this point
where you've got passive income takes a
long time and a lot of work and a lot of
headache and you're going to have gray
hairs and
um you're going to go through a lot of
crap to get there and um so it's it's
just not what you see on Instagram it's
not what you see on LinkedIn
um it's it takes a it takes a lot of
work and a lot of time that you
sometimes your lifestyle may not be set
up that way and honestly I don't know if
you if that should be a part of your
immediate goal it's all dependent on
your total Financial picture but
um it's it's not really an immediate
goal that you need to just have this
um
this income coming in the mailbox where
you don't have to do anything because it
is way harder than that and and the hard
comes from from your from you doing it
all these years is it from finding the
deal because that's one of the best ways
to do that if you get into real estate
investing once you have paid off your
your home you have no debt you have
savings retirement you do all the baby
steps the pain is it more on the front
ends of finding a good deal because you
talk about that buying a good deal on
the front end or is it the pain of
actually having the tenants
and having to manage maintenance the
people the rent I mean all of that yeah
no unless you're renting to a robot
um it's all all of it so uh when we were
when we were buying things it was every
30 offers you would get one contract
um and of those 30 offers most of them
weren't great deals
um and this was back in the recession in
2012 when people were begging for they
were begging for Deals they were begging
for a cash offer and it still took one
out of every 30. so uh it takes a ton of
time you got to be in the newspapers
looking for foreclosures you got to be
getting into the marketplace making
relationships with Brokers that that
will
um send you deals
um you got to be making relationships
with title companies to make sure that
you know and are aware of a clear title
when you're looking into something that
could be very risky so it's it's not a
it's not a um simple game and it's not a
risk-free game it's very risky it is a
huge financial decision but it should be
a part of your overall Financial picture
not the one thing the Silver Bullet that
allows you to not have to work yes
because I think that's it I think that's
that's the lie that we constantly try to
debunk on this show because again we get
these calls
all the time of like well I saw this and
this and I want to you know get have
some rental properties and all that but
I'm like the amount of work the amount
of efforts to even find the deal like
you're saying it's a whole other set of
knowledge right that you can learn I
mean not that no one is that you're not
capable of it but it's not the shoe-in
easy access you know idea of investing
yeah it really does it takes so much
work on the front end and then once you
do it again we we encourage all cash so
you're going to start small move at the
speed of cash uh but then also too the
the person in the house or in the condo
or in the town home that's renting uh
that's where that's another risk that if
you go and take on debts
and get a bunch of rental properties
those people that you're depending on to
pay the mortgage plus maybe some more
yeah that may not always happen yeah so
and so I will say the other side of the
coin is
it's amazing so I'm not saying oh this
is all pain and terrible it's amazing
but and it is doable so
you're nice first uh rental property was
a was a condo uh for forty two thousand
dollars
and we saved up forty two thousand
dollars and bought this one bedroom
condo and uh it's not nice oh it's gross
it was awful you know you put ten
thousand dollars into it and rented it
out and I thought I had made it like I
thought this is it and then you start
cashing the checks and you're like oh
oh there's seven hundred dollars oh
that's pretty cool that's pretty good
700 next month 700 next month
the 700 came in but the water heater
broke that's right and then you start
running that out you know over you know
every 12 months how much how much
rentaling can actually actually how much
rental income comes in
and then the actual expenses that it
takes to run that thing plus the amount
of people you have to deal with
and all of that headache chasing rent
um you're basically netting stuff a
thousand bucks yeah it's tough it's
tough the amount no we just now we did
sell that condo four years ago for 125
000 and that's the beauty of it right
but again that is it's long term and
difficult yep so we are We Are For Real
Estate we come my that's that's my dad's
whole story obviously that has helped
with Ramsey Solutions is like was in
real estate he loves real estate married
a guy who loves real estate so we are
all for it but doing it the smart way
the right way and just to debunk that
it's not this like just easy shoe and
passive income that it's made to be on
social media so we're gonna talk more
about that and take your calls here on
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour and while
most surms and personalities are out of
town which caused me to do a solo show
we thought it'd be fun to do a real
estate hour and bring on my husband
Winston Cruise talk about real estate
yeah good I thought it was because Dave
was out of town and y'all were doing the
show solo so we thought we'd just hijack
it but that's good to know just you know
it's our own rules when he's gone when
he's not in the when he's not good
tonight we get to do what we want I
parked in a I parked in a debt free spot
up that's okay for a family
I'm sure that's okay I think you can get
away with that all right so again we're
taking your calls when it comes to real
estate real estate investing and all the
things okay up first we have Andres in
Canada hey Andres welcome to the show
hello thanks so much for taking my call
I appreciate what you guys do so much I
live the Ramsay way so thank you so much
for what you do amazing well thanks for
calling how can we help
yeah um so I just want to hear your
feedback on investing in a quad Plex
um the last week I've heard a couple
different comments from your
personalities kind of poking fun uh at
the the quad Plex uh kind of investment
and but you guys haven't really
explained why and I'm in the middle of
uh kind of purchasing a quad Plex and
I'm paying all cash I am completely debt
free so I just wanted to kind of check
in and see if there's any kind of red
flags or anything that I need to be
aware of I have experience as a with a
rental property uh which I've sold and I
want to invest in a do a better
investment with a quad Plex okay and
this is this your only investment
property you had one that you sold and
you're gonna take the profits of that is
it to upgrade just have more units yeah
so I sold that one paid off the one I
went on the mortgage and I've I've made
a good amount of money and then uh
there's a quad price that I can uh buy
out in cash I have uh tenants already
with the leads ready to go and it brings
in about four thousand dollars a month
of income so that's great
um I'm curious with the other because
you said the other Ramsey personalities
on the show this week or last week were
kind of was it was it negative because a
single family home was just a
traditionally a better investment when
it comes to real estate is that what
they were saying I was trying to think
of exactly their concerns to help you
that was sort of these kind of point of
views around that but then Jade was kind
of Pokemon at uh people just my corner I
don't know if it's the investment itself
how they're acquiring the investment so
I just kind of wanted to yeah just get
some feedback if there's anything I need
to be aware of on a Quantum selection
investment specifically or in life if
you guys uh kind of give me your
blessing on if it was doing more of uh
yeah just people doing crazy things to
get into the uh the rental market
Andres uh I'm your biggest fan and uh
I'm not a personality so I think I can
say whatever I want
um
but um I uh are you are you uh what's
your what's your long-term goal with
this property
her goal right now it just seemed like I
was so I I love being debt free and I
wanted to get rid of the mortgage on
that rental property which is all the
data I had left and I had a ton of
equity in it so I did want to sell it
and uh and move into your uh yeah an
investment this thing before I cash and
this amazing deal just kind of came up
and uh I I don't think you know I don't
have any plans of buying and selling it
you know is not my goal my goal is to
get kind of more uh monthly income yeah
um well I love the idea obviously I love
that you would Own It debt free so that
4K goes in your pocket every month other
than taxes and insurance and whatever
problems you're going to have
um I like the quad Plex because it's
efficient you have is it local the
property is it local you can go see it
yeah I mean
okay guys uh so where I am
I'm using
um I think property does have
um uh has been a wife hooked to one of
the handyman in case there's any
emergency hey Andres can you talk hey
Andres can you talk directly into your
phone we're having a little trouble
hearing you
yes can you hear me there yeah that's
much better thank you okay uh yeah the
property has already
a uh uh husband and wife one of them is
the handyman who's just in case there's
any emergencies he's like there to fix
stuff uh if needed I mean there's a lady
as well his wife who does the cleaning
and does any showings if needed uh
because the current owner of that
property lives out of town so it's kind
of a well-packaged feel that
um you know all these connections are
there in place already so yeah yeah I
mean you're a smart guy you you've been
in the you've been in this deal before
uh with the property you just sold
um you know you're running a mini HOA
with four people living right next door
and sharing a wall so uh that would be
one of the downsides uh you there's more
potential for problems there
um yeah I I it sounds like you've even
gone and met the tenants and you know
you can feel in your gut what you're
getting into and when you try it on it
either fits or it doesn't
um so I I feel like your experience
you're checking all the boxes and then
the numbers on your return is just uh
your offer is whatever whatever you want
to make on it um I would typically
recommend though less than 10 percent
um after you run that 48 000 a year and
then minus your operating expenses gives
you your net operating income and I
would I would try to go for 10 off of
that number
um how much is it how much is it Andres
it's a 160 000. okay
I'm gonna move to Canada
yeah small town Canada uh right now
they're they're booming um and uh yeah
to me there's absolutely no it's like
from the investment
kind of you guys I I follow everything
you guys do carefully I have for quite a
few years now and it was just a little
yeah little comments here and they're
kind of poking fun at it but I've never
had her in the official kind of why yeah
and I I just people doing crazy things
getting in debt and stuff right no and I
think that's probably an element of it
uh kind of like get rich quick stuff we
were talking about the segment before
but I mean Winston have you found like
when you do duplexes quad plexes all
that is there potential for for more
issues more problems versus just a
single family home no dealing with one
time not necessarily you you do
um you do kind of narrow your exit
strategy a little bit with a quad or
duplex because you're not necessarily
going to get a single family but I don't
when you sell it uh down the road that's
why I asked what's your long-term plan
if you're gonna buy and hold and you're
gonna make your money back in two and a
half years on this thing uh it doesn't
matter
what kind of what kind of structure it
is
um you can sell it for whatever you want
to later on and it will go up in value
you just narrow the the market that
you're gonna uh market to in a seller
down the road
um
those are my thoughts is that whoever's
gonna buy this for me is going to be an
investor right is trying to get a deal
yep and by that time you're going to
have taken care of it so well that your
rent's gonna go up and they're going to
have they're going to make a different
percentage on it um that is going to be
higher than what you bought it for
exactly awesome well thank you guys for
your feedback I appreciate it for sure
absolutely thanks for calling us Andres
we are taking your real estate calls
this hour at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so you know when we
talk about investing in real estate
again just to be over communicate here
on the show it's after you're it's like
an Andres right you are completely debt
free including your home you've maxed
out retirements uh because so many of
our everyday millionaires we talk to I
mean so much of it is in their Primary
Home the equity there that is part of
their net worth and their Investments
you know you look at 401ks Roth IRAs
these have great track records they're
from a tax perspective are fantastic and
so being able to do that and go down
those Lanes first and foremost is what
we recommend and then after that is
where you can look to diversify your
your wealth building and for a lot of
people that is real estate when they get
to that point and so when you and Dave
dad went through all that I mean it was
a lot during the recession so again this
was 10 years ago when you guys did a lot
of your purchasing for people today that
may be in that position of baby step
seven they have some cash and like yeah
we want to get into it and pay cash for
Real Estate I mean people are having a
tough time buying a home for their
primary family right now do you find
that this
it would you hold right now and wait for
the market
I would if if you have cash in your
pocket and you're looking to get into
real estate I would be uh kind of
foaming at the mouth because it's gonna
it's it's happening the correction's
happening I hope for everybody that it's
not like it it wasn't 08 and I don't
think it will be yeah uh but things will
go on sale and that's the best time to
be waiting it out so good all right
again triple eight eight two five five
two two five at taking your real estate
calls I'm Rachel Cruz
coasting this hour for the first time
ever with my husband Winston Cruz
talking real estate this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back for their
watch and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with my
husband first time ever Winston Cruz and
real estate has been part of my family
forever and ever and ever and then
married a guy who loved real estate and
does it for a living as well so we
thought it would be fun while all the
Rams personalities were gone to kind of
hijack the show and and have and have a
discussion around investment real estate
because it's a hot topic for a lot of
people and all over social media it's
just kind of the new it feels like the
thing not new thing but it's the thing
people want to get into to build wealth
so we're taking your calls this hour at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so up next we have Kyle in Atlanta
Georgia hey Kyle welcome to the show
how's it going how's it going thanks for
having me yep absolutely how can we help
yeah I was just curious um kind of
really straightforward here is whether
it's a larger sum of money like if
somebody right now you know in this
market had somewhere between you know
200 250
000 to potentially play with would it
make sense to be investing in the real
estate space right now or to stay in
more of your traditional Investments or
stocks yeah that's a great question so
Kyle I'm assuming you're asking for
yourself right these numbers and and
everything is kind of where you're at
um so if if that's the case where where
are you financially overall do you have
Consumer Debt do you have other savings
besides this to 275 000. yes so there's
savings uh not a lot of Consumer Debt uh
debt on a current house
um you know that we're in right now or
or you know just like owing on a
mortgage so I'm kind of curious I was
gonna
yeah so we have about 400 left on that
so that's going to be kind of my
follow-up is would it make sense to
invest in the currents or just to
contribute to the current space we're in
or to be looking outwardly yeah uh well
it's a it's a great question and so one
of the things we talk about because I
know you said you have some Consumer
Debt so I would encourage you to take
some of this cash and throw it at that
and just become debt free from Consumer
Debt whether that's student loans or
credit cards personal loans and then
take some of that 275 and put it in a
high yield savings account or a money
market account for three to six months
of expenses for an emergency fund and so
once you kind of clear all of that then
I would first and foremost go through
and max out what you can when it comes
to your 401k a Roth IRA how much do you
guys make a year
say one more time you you
you cut out sorry about that together
combined my wife and I about 600 to 650
000. okay so okay
um well you guys make a great income
Kyle so if I were in your shoes I mean I
would go ahead and I and limit some
lifestyle and knock out this mortgage
um and and then it sets you up at that
point to max out all retirement and then
look at other options which would be
real estate so I would use that 250 to
throw throw at your mortgage and the
income you have and then if we look
forward Kyle you know three three years
from now just to just to throw a
timeline out there where your everything
is paid off
you guys have a great income you have
cash that you're just saving saving
saving and you get back to this point of
having maybe you know 250 300 000 in the
bank then that's when I feel like real
estate investing could come into play
where you can start thinking about that
great guys Winston uh I I uh I I want
you to have real estate
um I love your question and I if you're
if I were you I'd be thinking I've got
250 to play with and I I would love to
have some fun with it in real estate
um at the same time you don't need you
really don't need income at this point
and you're all's Financial Journey
uh so my my thought would be similar to
Rachel's we were married so we we've
gone through some of this before shared
the same way but uh I would I would get
some of that debt off your back
um and then later on start to think okay
I you know that that 250 is going to
turn into something bigger in the future
when passive income can allow you to do
certain things with your life that you
may not be able to do now from a Time
perspective
um but the reason you would be putting
250 somewhere would not be for your
income you'd be doing it just so you can
start to build equity in a in a
secondary home or a rental property but
you don't really need to you've got
great income you you've got a giant
shovel to pay off that debt
it will it would be fun today to do real
estate it will be so much better later
when you can do it without that debt
um taking away some of that income
yeah that's great advice awesome great
thanks Kyle thank you yes I think that's
one of the the big things is getting
everything in your in your home in your
life right so your primary home again
going back to investing in those just
traditional retirement vehicles that we
talk about all the time and doing all of
that and then when it's freed up so in
his case has a great income when you're
making 600 Grand a year he doesn't you
know
he didn't need the the 700 mailbox money
coming from you know a condo so if it's
in that case do you then look at like
yeah if you get into real estate at that
point it's so long-term thinking
that it's all about the equity at that
point then the quote unquote passive
income coming in because you're not in
need of that like you know what I'm
saying like is the mindset difference
when you're trying to do it for income
versus just long-term investing maybe
even generationally yeah it's a it's a
risk game so you're moving the risk even
if you could pay he could pay cash for a
property today with that 250 but he's
still got this debt the 400 000 of debt
so you still got risk there
but if you go leverage a piece of
property and you pay off your house or
whatever the 400 000 is
then you've got risk on the on the
property so it's like right if you have
600 000 coming in every year go pay off
your debt and then build up a big old
fund and and go buy a piece of real
estate that's actually going to you're
going to feel it every month because if
you go buy a 250 000 piece of real
estate unless you're Andres up in Canada
uh making 48 000 a year on 160 000. then
you're just you're not it's not going to
change your life yeah it's not gonna
change your life and that's that's the
other that's the other lie is that if I
go buy a house it's going to change my
life no it's not it's gonna be a
thousand dollars a month and then the
HVAC is going to go out and then you're
going to Net Zero the first year after
your operating expenses
and uh you're gonna ask yourself oh this
isn't as fun as I thought it was because
they got a cat and I said no pets and
now I have to deal with the cat has that
happened Winston tell us about the cats
I have said no to a thousand four-legged
animals and they all act like it's a
personal family member uh uh I would say
for a lot they do it is oh they're all
mad at me and I'm like well it says no
pets no smoke
and they they say it's the only dog in
the world that doesn't
poop anywhere or like it is the only cat
that doesn't shed and I'm like even if
it's a skinless or a furless cat they're
so ugly that you can't have one in my
property so now they're uh yeah it
happens all that's why people go around
the system and go get a go get an animal
and then you got to go in there and bust
the thing up like you're doing a drug
deal is that your number one piece of
advice for lamb if you're a landlord if
you are buying an investment property
you are Andres having the quad Plex up
in Canada
is no animals like is that your number
one I think it's a personal decision
because people would pay ten thousand
dollars for their personal family member
four-legged family member on a security
deposit uh so that's it's a it's it's up
to you the investor
um I'm just trying to reduce headache
and turnover cost and the drama of it
but people are getting ESA
uh emotional support animals now yeah as
a way to get around it yes out let me
just say this it is legit yeah like
there are people that have the papers
that need to do it but there's also
strategies that have popped up now
because of all the animal policies and
um people have a guinea pig that they
pet when they start to have a increase
heart rate you know and it's like that's
that doesn't qualify in my house but no
guinea pigs
even in it no even in it no no no but
that's a personal decision for the
investor uh George Campbell was on here
a few months ago and said something
about a horse and all of it and he got
some hate on YouTube so I will be
curious about the comments I felt like
guinea pig was a safe play
that was probably the safest you could
have done well done you're a pro
thanks for having me
all right again taking your questions
when it comes to real estate and
specifically investment real estate here
on the Ramsey Show triple eight eight
two five five two two five
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
well if you haven't heard we're doing
something around here that we've
actually never done before two things
actually this hour of the Ramsey Show
co-hosting with my husband Winston
talking about real estate but also all
the Ramsay personalities are leading a
Financial Peace University class
including myself and I want you to join
my virtual class so we're really excited
about this you're going to learn
everything you need to know when it
comes to handling your money how to pay
off debt how to build wealth all of it
and I'm going to be your personal
cheerleader through that class plus you
are going to be part of a community of
thousands of other people in each class
so again this is one of the best ways to
learn how to handle your monies through
Financial Peace University so there are
a few days left for my class my class
starts uh next Monday and Mondays and
Wednesdays during the lunch hour from 1
pm Eastern Time to 2 p.m eastern time
will be my class Jade warshaw starts an
evening class and that same time and
it's about four and a half weeks to go
through all nine lessons and then all
the other Ramsay personalities will be
doing a class later this summer so to
find out more and to sign up for my
class because we're gonna have a lot of
fun I promise go to fpu.com to sign up
today again that's fpu.com and my class
starts on Monday
all right our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services
neighborly.com is the place to find
Reliable help for your home from locally
owned businesses like air serve dryer
vent wizard Precision guard for your
garage door window Genie and more for
expert help with everything you need to
know go to neighborly.com and today's
question comes from Daniel in New Jersey
I see many multi-family real estate
investment groups on LinkedIn and other
platforms what are your thoughts on
investing with these groups many of them
require a minimum investment of thirty
five thousand dollars it is my
understanding that this investment is to
grow Capital needed to construct or
purchase an apartment complex or condo
type housing the payouts come at an
undetermined point in the future am I
missing the Mark or am I or I'm sorry am
I on Mark or am I missing the target is
this a risky investment
oh man Daniel Daniel Daniel just keep
scrolling down and then there is no way
I would ever do 35
000 of something based on something on
LinkedIn
um even especially in real estate
investment so yeah
um yeah that's they're probably funding
something that um
is a big
uh crowdfunded thing to get a project
done and there's going to be a lot of
small print it's going to be uh not
guaranteed you're going to have to have
an attorney look over the documents uh
if I have 35 000 there's no way I'm
doing anything with anybody that big
where I just put it into a a bucket of
the abyss and hopefully there's a pre
predetermined payout in the future
um if you're going to do something that
boring uh you should check with your
financial advisor because most of the
time they're going to have a certain
amount of funds that you've given them
to work with that will be in a real
estate investment trust or a Reit so
effect you could be effectively doing
that and not even know it yet I would
check with your advisor on that but
you're you probably
um you could ask them uh how much of
your investment is is in a Reit along
with your mutual funds and things like
that because that's how boring it is I I
would rather do something on my own
where I control everything and I can go
see and touch and feel the house or the
investment property
as opposed to finding something on
LinkedIn and just writing a blind check
to it no Daniel no the answer is no but
there are these groups though again not
35 000 but
um and I feel like we even had a family
friend talk about this where it's like
you kind of you do you pull your money
together
a bunch of investors and they go buy
something in Phoenix or whatever right
and they and they have Investments other
places and they get a portion a
percentage
of the equity payout or whatever it is
so like yeah even those shared you have
a lot of caution it can work but I would
I would check with that company and make
them show you
a track record of everything that
they've ever done in the past
um because
there is nothing guaranteed it's highly
risky they could go they could go fund
do a capital raise for the for an
investment across the country that
you've never seen before and then that
company goes up
or the economies continues to slow down
like you talked about earlier this show
um and then the thing just gets put on
hold or even worse you just lose all
your money
um I'd rather do it through real estate
investment trusts that's just stable
steady if you're going to do something
like that again there's no big payout
scenario that's worth the risk yeah it's
good all right we're going to the phones
at this hour and Leland is in Olympia
Washington hey Leland welcome to the
show
hi Rachel hi I'm Winston
um my question was I have bought a
property last year in the spring for 60
000 and I just met the realtor a couple
days ago out there and he says he could
get 135 for it in during the um course
of the summer me and my wife bought a
property in Romania we plan to move
there as missionaries
I am so now my thought is should I take
that 100
000 the properties paid off so should I
take that 100
000 120 whatever it is and buy another
property that I could rent out close to
my in-laws in New York where I can
afford it
um that's a great question how are you
paying for the home in Romania
cash it's a cheap house okay yeah yeah
yeah the economy is terrible over there
okay okay yeah
um that's awesome okay and and your hope
is to take this you do you guys need any
amount of cash you have enough savings
for you guys when you live over there as
missionaries to be able to sustain the
lifestyle that you guys want
yeah we do um we have enough cash to or
we will have enough cash to live my goal
is to live there for at least a year
have enough to live there for at least a
year before I start seeing what I can do
to make money around there
um and support myself so it's kind of
the idea with this property is
should I you know I can't buy a property
around here in Washington because the
land is so expensive but back in Upstate
New York where my wife where my wife's
from the um land is really cheap and I
could buy like a hundred thousand dollar
property and rent on it it's like 12.50
a month so is it stupid to do that so
far away
I mean being a long distance landlord
I'll have Winston kind of speak into
that
um my other question before we get into
it Leland I just want to make sure do
you guys have any any other like
retirement invest Investments anywhere
else do you have any other money saved
no I have a very small 401K okay okay
yeah Leland I I um I wouldn't rush to do
anything if if you're for this
projection for Romania is one year
um that money is not going to go
anywhere I I would it's not going to
burn a hole in your pocket and fall out
I would keep it just in a in the bank
um until you figure out something that's
a little more long-term than 12 months
so is there is there a bigger reason why
you're wanting to rush into getting
something and renting it out
well I might have said that wrong we're
not um we're planning to be over there
indefinitely okay in Romania
um but we might you know things can fall
apart something could happen 10 years
from now 20 years from now okay
I heard you
yeah and then also we'll probably come
home every year well not every year but
like every several years because the
hospital's over there so bad so we come
home for my wife to have a baby whatever
and this would be a place I could stay
not a place I could stay but I could
stay with her folks and you know fix up
their property in the meantime
I
um
if it feels a little bit out of balance
to based on the financial picture you've
given us to put that amount of money
into real estate
um compared to your cash on hand your
401k and where what you're going to be
doing overseas
I feel like that's just stress and
headache you don't want uh I would let
Rachel take over and tell you what she
would do with the cash but um I think
real estate would be a hold on for now
yeah I mean Leland I
if I were your wife even if we're going
to be moving across the globe and
knowing yeah things like Health Care
aren't great
um like even the economic state of it
like you're saying even that feels
unstable
um there's not a ton in a 401k all of
that having more cash on hand that you
can get to I think is going to give you
guys a peace of mind that a rental
property just won't and again we
understand the math and how exciting it
is to get in it and you know get that
rent every month but like we were saying
earlier it's just a lot of work and
doing that as a long distance landlord I
probably would not in your situation but
you guys are incredible uh you and your
wife so thanks for everything that
you're doing and just absolutely giving
your life up to service it's absolutely
incredible so uh Winston thanks for
being a guest on this hour thank you
love you love you too love all this
wisdom and appreciate that and a bunch
of mistakes thank you America for
listening this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
well do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am Ramsey
personality Rachel Cruz hosting this
hour of the Ramsay show and taking your
calls from anywhere in the country it's
a free call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and starting us
off this hour is Jacob in Tacoma
Washington hey Jacob welcome to the show
hi Rachel how's it going doing well how
can I help
my wife and I are both active duty in
the military and we're deciding whether
we should buy land before we get out or
after we get out okay well thank you
guys for your service
um when is your date to to be out what
are you guys thinking
uh my minimum year is 2027 before I can
get out okay and how about your wife
uh hers is 2024. 2024 okay so she's
before and are you guys moving uh will
you do you see yourself moving again in
between now and 2027
definitely okay
uh do you guys know where you want to be
planted long term do you know like where
you would want to buy land or is there a
piece of specific land you're looking at
uh right now we're working in the Casper
Wyoming area
okay and is there a piece of land that
you want or you guys know you just want
to settle there in 2027.
uh there's one piece of land that we
found that we're interested in there's
about 40 acres okay but it's not like a
um
sentimental piece of lands that you've
grown up with generationally like
there's not like a specific one that
you're like oh gosh we want to we want
to you know buy this for our family it's
more just the idea I we want to buy
before the market goes up or what's your
like kind of what's the motivation
around it
uh yeah there's nothing sentimental or
like a specific piece of land we
absolutely have to have
um we uh just know that when we get out
we definitely want to just have our own
piece of land and we just want to be
able to stay there so we're trying to
just figure out
when in case the market goes up or okay
yeah and whether I stay in for 20 years
or not yeah and are you wanting a home
on this lands is that what you're
looking for
so you can move into it when you guys
are done okay
that's great are you guys do you have
any do you have any debt what's your
what's your savings your savings like uh
we have no debt
um we have a full three-month uh
emergency fund which I think is like at
18. right now that's great and of course
our savings is that like 11 right now
um nice
um and then we have our investments and
stuff which I don't remember exactly
what that sits at right now okay do you
guys have any kids
uh not yet we are crying okay good
um well you know if I were you Jacob I
probably would just wait until you guys
get out of the military and see where
you're at because just a lot can change
in four years and being locked into a
piece of property that you're not even
really going to use for four years
I don't think it's a great investment of
your money right now I think I would
rather have money just in the markets or
just cash on hand as you guys make all
these Transitions and these moves
between now and 20 and and uh 2027. so
yeah if I were to wake up in your shoes
Jacob I would I would wait until after
um you guys are out and you know where
you want to settle
um because the crazy thing is too you
know a lot changes in four years whether
that's kids and that's family or even
maybe you guys are stationed in another
uh part of the country that you fall in
love with then you're like oh man I wish
you know we we didn't have this land
locked in and we have to go and sell it
and it ends up instead of it being a
long-term play it ends up being a
short-term play and I don't want you to
make you know a bad financial move on
that end uh considering where the market
is so if I were you guys I would be
renting I would just save up a lot of
cash and then when you guys are out in
2027 look to buy something permanent
with the cash that you have hopefully is
a good down payment so thanks so much
for the call Jacob and thank you and
your wife both uh for your service
military members are just we really are
appreciative so thank you thank you for
your service all right up next we have
Brooke in Houston Texas hey Brooke
welcome to the show
hi Rachel how are you doing well thanks
for calling how can we help
so my husband and I are kind of planning
on moving homes in the next two to three
years and we're currently in babysit
four five and six and we didn't know if
we should continue baby step six of
paying down our current mortgage or
should we kind of pause that and put any
extra cash aside into a high old savings
account
um we might want to buy some land and
build on or we might want to just buy a
house
okay
um how much how much you guys have left
on the house
we have 133 000 100 and how much do you
guys make a year
about 105 take home okay that's great
well you know the way I kind of look at
this Brook always is when you are paying
into the home and paying it down and
you're having that Equity that's that's
guaranteed cash for the most part right
I mean I don't think the Market's gonna
go I don't think it's going to tank like
you know there are some people that had
to Doomsday approach when it comes to
real estate I just don't think it's
going to happen uh things are slowing
down they're softening we're seeing that
but I don't think there's going to be a
crash so I do think what you will have
in equity that you're putting in as
you're paying off this home will
continue to grow and so what I kind of
like still about the idea of just paying
down the mortgage even though you know
you may move is number one you never
know what life's gonna happen and you
may not who knows right you you could
get three years down the road and
something were to happen with your
family or circumstances change and you
end up staying in that home but you've
been paying it down and then the second
thing is that that cash is kind of
locked into the house so when you guys
sell it and you get the equity out you
know that that has been saved versus
putting money in a high yield savings
accounts that can sometimes sometimes
easily be spent on things like a summer
vacation or something ends up happening
and you're like oh my gosh you know we
we had this money so we do stress in
four five and six to be intentional not
to be not to be intense so intense
intensity is through that you know one
through three steps and so what I would
say is still enjoy your life I would
still you know to to the point that you
guys are that you're still enjoying your
life but putting some money away by
paying off that house
um early continuing down that path I
think is the best bet because again that
money's locked into that Hall but when
you sell it you'll have the equity
versus when it's in a high yield savings
accounts it we can you know you your
idea is yeah we can use that for a down
payment later on but sometimes life ends
up happening you end up spending it
very
ramsay-esque in the way I think so no
it's great yeah and I think it's a great
question because a lot of people you
know have that and then even some people
have asked do I take some of this cash
and start redoing things in my home for
resale value even do I you know do we
change
um things and update our home to even
get more when we sell in two to three
years and even those I would be careful
because there's some stuff that you know
if you guys went down that road and for
some people certain things are an
upgrade and then to majority of people
when they're going to buy a home it's
not an upgrade at all and you lose your
money in that so I would just continue
to pay it on the mortgage and then when
you guys decide to move you'll have all
that Equity that can be moved to another
home but it's a great question Brooke
thanks for calling this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour and it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and we mentioned earlier but our
team is out in Anaheim California
Southern California for our Building
Wealth events and so I thought since
they're not in studio it'd be fun for
them to call in and say hi and and talk
for a little bit so I have Jade warshar
our other Ramsay personality on the line
hey Jade
what is up Rachel Cruz what's going
what's going on how are you how's how's
California
man it's treating us good it's a bright
sunny day partly cloudy skies feeling
good just doing great well I heard from
Ken in an earlier segment that you guys
are staying like right by Disneyland
yeah I think I see what is Disneyland
across the street I mean some Ferris
wheels and whatnot yes that's so fun
that's so fun well I know for so many
people travel and so many families that
this is the thing that we're about to
enter upon right with with Summer here
summer break so many families travel
maybe coming to Disneyland where you
guys are and there's just a lot of
expense when it comes to travel I know
you and I have talked about this being
moms and having little ones and there's
the price to pay for convenience
sometimes when you travel but also
sometimes it just costs you so much and
it's not worth it so what when when you
guys travel what are the things that
you're like oh yeah that's worth it and
that's that's probably not
oh man you know traveling is it's I'm
definitely starting to notice things
that might be worth spending a little
bit extra for for the convenience Rachel
I think you know this before I came to
Ramsey Solutions I traveled primarily
for my work because we worked on cruise
lines so we were traveling all around
the world and honestly back then I would
just do bare minimum you know we were
trying to pay off debt so it was more
just about let's just get there and
instead of spending a bunch of money on
experiences and things like that we just
would walk around we'd eat and just try
to do things on the cheap but now I'm
realizing you know there's some things
now that I have kids it's worth paying
for like a good piece of luggage can I
just say yes like I don't want to be
carrying like duffel bags and backpacks
and things that are breaking my back I
want just one like good piece of luggage
that's got the four wheels on it it
swivels you know what I'm saying and you
can't I'm an airport I'm a suitcase
Pusher I put all was up on four wheels
and I and I pushed that thing next to me
on this side instead of dragging behind
that's the way I go about airports so
I'm I'm with you
yeah I mean the bag I have I've
literally had it for 10 years it's a
great bag it wasn't super expensive but
it wasn't just you know something that I
picked up at Walmart it was a decent bag
that I bought at Macy's and honestly on
this trip I'll be 100 transparent I
valeted my car have you ever done that
you know what Jay this is one of the
luxuries in life that I will pay for
some people make fun of me because I
know it's kind of expensive but to just
be in and out of your car right there at
the airport door it's worth it versus
doing long-term parking for me so that
is a baby step seven thing that I am
enjoying with the margin that we have
are you okay how has it felt do you like
it is it worth it
I mean I had never done it before and I
was like a girl can get used to this
now but here's the thing balanced with
Southwestern
you know what I'm saying yep you you
pick it's like you pick the things that
are important to you whereas you know
flying Southwest it's not as expensive
as some of these other lines I would
definitely categorize it in more of a
bargain
um airline with maybe not as far as
Spirit but you know like Southwest you
can usually find a good deal yes for
sure like if you find a good deal on the
tickets then maybe you can find a way to
splurge on things like you know parking
at the airport or you know once you get
it on the trip here's another one I
bring snacks from home on the airplane I
do not buy snacks in the airport oh we
do the same I'll buy the uncrustable
sandwiches I'm like sorry guys your
lunch is right here in the backpack that
we're gonna take out and eat I know we
just we did a trip in March with the
kids and it was the first time we took
them into a you know the gift shop area
and I did let them buy one thing of
candy because they were just so excited
but that's the first time we've ever
done that because I'm like and it is you
get that you get up there and it's like
20 something bucks for three bags of
candy was like this is this is silly oh
yeah it's unbelievable and then you feel
you find yourself like having to say no
a lot which is not fun you know what I
mean on a trip it's not fun to have to
say no to yourself and to your kids but
if you have all that stuff in your bag
if you brought all the snacks that you
know you like your kids enjoy then you
can just open up your bag and say what
do you guys want and the answer can be
yes which I personally love on my trip
here I always bring like cheese puffs I
always bring like some kind of Trail Mix
and then I'm depending on the fact that
they're gonna at least give me a bottle
of water now if you're on Spirit they
may not give you a bottle of wine that's
right
yeah I think that's great Jaden I love
even just the picture of the budget
because when you have the amount of
money you want to spend within that
you're like hey here's where I'm going
to cut here's where I'm going to splurge
and it's all within this dollar amount
so that's so great Jade I hope you guys
have a great event tonight it's almost
what over 2 000 people we all all be
together in Anaheim tonight for the
Building Wealth events are you excited
I'm so excited I was in here picking out
my outfit trying to get my wardrobe on
lock but the most important thing is
tonight we're going to be in a room like
you said 2 000 people and it's going to
be honest life change I love getting to
meet people talk eye to eye with them
get to shake their hands and really see
the impact that this message is having
on real people's lives yeah it's so
great oh well Jade thank you so much for
calling in and I love hearing from you
guys on the roads you all are very
missed here in Nashville but I know that
message is going to be so powerful there
in Southern California tonight all right
we're gonna go to the phones and we have
Julie in Kansas City up next hey Julie
welcome to the show
all right thanks for having me and
protecting my information and taking on
my problem today absolutely how can I
help
um well I have two credit cards from two
different accounts so not related
they're not related accounts uh from a
business I was uh running in 2018 I had
three employees and I was using these
credit cards for to buy supplies with
and then I moved out of that stage and
the business was okay but I thought I
could do all that and then pay off the
cards as the business was going on and
then coveted
and then all of the sales that I was
having which I was doing really well uh
right after covert um because I did a
lot of um sales for the church and so a
lot of churches stopped you know having
Services all that and so then
um and so then I moved to another state
and that didn't work out so then I made
to a third state and then I started
having health problems so that was five
years ago that I think the last time the
cards were active was 2018. I'd like to
consolidate the cards if possible
probably not anyway yeah to One account
how much do you owe on each of the cards
well I would say a total of both of them
seven thousand it's not a lot but it is
a lot for me because I'm pretty Limited
in my income I don't really have a lot
of income it's true how much are you
making a year would you say well I'm on
disability I'm legally blind and legally
deaf so
yeah I'm really in a hard slot and I've
been just three weeks ago had my fourth
cornea insurance plan and I only see out
of I only have Vision in my eye so I'm
so sorry now I'm living on yeah it's
it's really been a hard hard Road and
and I like I said I had my own business
for 23 years and I had designs and all
these different nations so I'm not like
someone who sits around all day but
anyway
um have you been and you haven't been
paying on these on these two accounts
these two cards
I haven't I just couldn't I have so much
like like I was trying to describe my
life as a whirlwind there was so much
going on and then I started having eye
problems yeah so okay so Julie I want to
um have you had creditors call you have
they have they tried to contact you
um no because I don't know where I am
okay and
um yeah they just don't know how to get
in touch with me but I know how to get
in touch with them yeah I know where
they are okay so yeah no it's great well
uh what I would say Julie is I would
contact them I would make a plan to say
okay here's what I can do and they may
even settle with you since it's been
five years and if it's moved to a
creditor
um you know and it's in collections even
usually they will settle with you so if
they do get that in writing and then
have a plan to pay it off because I want
this off your report I want this out of
your life because it's still hanging out
and I and I don't like that for you so I
know that you're working hard in your
own business and you're incredible
absolutely incredible doing all this
um with you said being legally blind and
deaf so um I would have a plan to
negotiate that and pay it down
[Music]
thank you
well it seems like there's an official
day for everything now there's Barefoot
day bad poetry Day dance like a chicken
day seriously can't make this stuff up
and there is one day I can get on board
with though National Life Insurance day
yep so it's a reminder that if you have
anyone in your life that depends on your
income like little kids running around
then getting life insurance needs to be
your top priority if you've been
listening to our show for a decade or
even a day you know that we only
recommend term life insurance but we
also teach that you need to be wise with
your money so how much can you expect a
Term Policy to cost you every month well
we have a tool that actually does the
work for crunching those numbers for you
you just enter in some basic info on our
term life estimator to get an idea of
how much it'll cost and the cool thing
is you don't have to enter any contact
info so all it takes is just a little
time a little bit of typing and you'll
get the results so get your estimate
today so you can know how much term life
will cost you so you can put it into
your budget and get covered today like
right now life insurance you guys is so
important to have if you have people
depending upon your income even you
stay-at-home moms and the the value you
bring to the home you need to be covered
with life insurance so go to Dave Rams
I'm sorry go to ramsesolutions.com term
estimate again that's
ramsesolutions.com term estimates
all right up next we have Rachel in
Lancaster Pennsylvania hey Rachel
welcome to the show
hey Rachel how you doing doing well love
the name thanks for calling obviously
obviously
how can I help
okay so my husband and I have three
loans right now two of which are small
totaling eight thousand dollars that
don't have any interest whatsoever for
the life of the loan and then the third
one is about 45
000 at five percent interest and
um I I know the baby steps say to go for
the small one first but if there is no
interest whatsoever would it be more
beneficial in the long run to go for the
45 000 with the interest first so that
we don't have as much interest in the
long run
yeah well you know
um mathematically you're correct right
if we were just doing math then yeah it
would obviously make sense to pay off
the highest interest rate first but what
we have found Rachel with paying off
debt it is so much more than a math
issue there's so much around the person
doing it the motivation that is caused
when you pay off that smallest debt the
wins that you get by paying off that
small stat so I I would still tell you
even if those two small steps tell me
how much are they did you say if each
one the two small ones one is 1900 the
other one's 6300 okay and how much you
guys make a year
uh
probably about 160. 160 okay
so here's what here's what I love about
this Rachel about the debt snowballs I'm
like okay yeah you guys make a great
income
take your budget for next month and just
cut everything out of it I mean honestly
pause subscriptions don't go out to eat
don't go shopping do nothing and you
guys are going to be able to knock out
that 1900 probably next month you can be
like we're gonna we're gonna just
absolutely Scorch Earth our life get
that out of the way and I'm telling you
there's something freeing about even
having a small debt paid off where it's
gone it's over and you're like oh okay
we only have two more left and then you
do the same thing that 20 that that 6300
you guys take a few months knock that
out and then and then you can focus all
of your time all of your energy on the
45 000 loan because even though they
don't have interest you guys are going
to pay it off so much faster that you're
going to get to the higher interest rate
loan of the 45 000 soon right it's not
like you're gonna be having that around
forever and never getting to it so by
paying off those smaller ones you are
going to get those wins and you don't
have to think about it it's less it's
less brain calories right if you're if
if things are paid off the smaller
little ankle we call them ankle biting
ones right they're just kind of swimming
around there once they're done it's like
oh we're cleared and we are focused on
one thing and one thing only
right so okay yeah that's really the the
mindset behind the debt snowball but
you're right if we were doing math that
would be the debt Avalanche where you
pay off the highest interest rate first
but there is something to be said again
where you take math out of the equation
and you just say let's just let's start
this habit of our life where we are
going to take everything out of the
budget that we can we're going to take
on extra jobs we're going to squeeze as
much money as we can month to month and
pay off the smallest debt first when you
get those wins it keeps you motivated
I'm telling you there was a study done
between people doing the debt Avalanche
and the debt snowball and those doing
the debt snowball paid it off faster
than those doing the Avalanche and again
it's paying off debt so we like we want
you to be debt free that's the end goal
anyways uh but it's still the most
efficient way to do it because personal
finance it's 80 Behavior it's only 20
head knowledge and so what does not come
into play for people when they're
looking at money is they look strictly
at the numbers in the math they don't
take it into account the person on the
other side doing the work so so you
Rachel and your husband you guys are it
like y'all are the secret sauce in all
of this and when you guys when you guys
are motivated and you're excited about
this you're going to pay off that 45 000
even faster so that's what I would
recommend but it's a it's a great
question all right up next we have Megan
in Columbus Ohio hey Megan welcome to
the show
hi Rachel thanks for talking with me
how's it going absolutely thanks for
calling how can I help
um so first of all I'm answering your
plea on Instagram to call in while
you're hosting I know I did I put on
stories I was like y'all I'm gonna be
hosting this show for three hours call
in and talk to me and you did Megan you
answered the call I so appreciate it I
feel so loved absolutely
um well my I have two questions
um my first question actually pertains
to um your book recommendations which
have been awesome
um all the books you've recommended have
been great I just finished the perfect
marriage oh yes my husband called the
end of that book after I read the first
chapter like and I don't know what that
means but I will say that one yeah it
was a little bit of a predictor of of
maybe the aunt or your husband knows too
much about murder mystery books
exactly so thank you for that um so my
first question is what is your what's
your next book recommendation
um and then question number two how did
you convince Winston to finally make his
social media appearance and even be on
the show with you because my husband is
the same way he hates social media so
I'm wondering what tricks you use to get
your husband on social media that's so
funny that's so funny okay well the book
recommendations will go there for first
okay if you're wanting I just wrote some
down
um another mystery type book The House
made
it's great it's really good it's a
popular one right now if you're a book
lover I feel like people see that uh if
you want to I love World War II that
kind of genre of books so the
Nightingale
is so great by Chris by Kristen Hannah
it's it's a great one uh if you want a
Little Love in Your Life this summer it
ends with us by Colleen Hoover is a
great one they're actually doing a uh a
movie and Blake Lively is going to be
the main actress in it she's gonna play
the main character so oh that's I okay
so I just read both of those books by
your recommendation and I was really
hoping they were doing a movie about it
because I was obsessed with those events
they're so good yep so if all you ladies
out there need a good summer read it
ends with us and it starts with us it's
a great series Colleen Hoover and then
okay and then one book I read and I put
it on Instagram because I all the ones
all the books I read I put out there is
the Comfort crisis so we read this book
as a Ramsay family over Christmas we
were all on a trip and we like got
passed around but it's a really great
one so it's it's a it's a non-fiction
all the other ones we were talking about
were fiction books uh but it's just
about how we why we don't specifically
in America push ourselves physically
mentally all of it
to the to a point of pain to have
sacrifice to get a result right we want
everything Comfort like even we have you
know 69 degrees everywhere you go you
get in the car you can turn on the
temperature you want there's no we we
are not we are in a comfortable Society
physically and then that plays into it
mentally and then you put technology on
it all of it I it's it's a great book
it's kind of more of a of a guy book
because he talks about this like big
hunt that he does in Alaska and all of
that um but his points in it are they're
so good because it pertains a lot to
what we talk about here on the Ramsey
Show with money that in order to get out
of debt you have to sacrifice you're
going to be uncomfortable and being
uncomfortable usually gets you a great
result when you're just comfortable all
the time you're in the status quo quo so
there's that and then Winston I know you
know he he had a slight career change
recently and he's just kind of embracing
more of my social media in my life which
I'm so glad because he's so wise and
he's so smart and I love him so the fact
that he's
getting on a little bit more and then
did the show today earlier is just I
can't believe it but I love it because I
love you guys getting to know him well
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
comes from Psalm 139 14 I praise you for
I am fearfully and wonderfully made
wonderful are your Works my soul knows
it very well
when you don't dress like everybody else
you don't have to think like everybody
else iris is an app Phil who's a fashion
icon and interior designer when you
don't dress like everyone else you don't
have to think like everyone else hey
I believe it that's great that's great
all right I am Rachel Cruz taking your
calls this hour and up next we have
Jason in Boise Idaho hey Jason welcome
to the show
hey Rachel how are you doing doing well
how can I help
a quick question
um so my wife is getting ready to
um uh get a closing on one of her um her
listings and we're making good traction
we've been paying off debt um like crazy
and we're super super busy I mean last
night we got I got paid
um with my job on the first and the 15th
and every um every two weeks it's like I
feel like we're at midnight paying bills
doing our budget Faithfully so her and I
were talking last night how would you or
what would you do if uh with one of the
closings if we took
um
a small portion of that that money and
stuck it in an account so each month
we're one month ahead I mean our
emergency funds still funded we're not
going to be taking that thousand or
anything but we're just gonna put
everything
um in an account and I set everything up
all of our utilities and everything on
autopay through my debit card not credit
card yeah just so we're a month ahead
yeah why don't you just do that for your
checking account
yeah I just wanted your opinion uh
instead of because we we'd be taken
roughly about thirty eight hundred
dollars out of this um this house
closing
um and instead of putting it towards
debt um this next month we would be
putting that in an account just so we're
a month ahead and we're not doing budget
every single you know two weeks we'd be
doing budget once a month oh I hear what
you're saying I hear what you're saying
yes
um yeah I'm all for that I think even
getting to that point because for a lot
of people living paycheck to paycheck
they don't even have the margin they
have to you know they have to
take the in the paycheck from the first
to use it and then once they get the
15th they have to use that right versus
if you have some buffer exactly what
you're talking about and your checking
account then you're able to go ahead and
just pay everything at the same time and
stay kind of ahead of it uh versus
waiting on the other paycheck so no I'm
great with that yeah I think that that's
really smart uh and if you can get to
that point it's it's a it's a nice point
to get to again because you're not
literally waiting on the other paycheck
and so yeah I think that'd be wise in I
don't even think you have to open up
another I mean unless you guys want to
but you can even just do some of that
auto auto drafting auto pay out of your
checking account just knowing yeah that
money is going to come out of that with
that 3 800 in your checking account
perfect you answered my questions yep
awesome well thanks for the call Jason
yeah I think the only time we're
cautious about auto anything is
sometimes auto savings uh if you just
put just put it on auto savings you know
it's fine but we want you to be very
intentional when it comes to your money
and so even that with savings uh can
kind of lose that point of hey I'm doing
this really on purpose and I can change
it month to month I can add more if I
need to so sometimes the auto savings is
one that we say hey just do it
purposefully but when there's bills like
utilities cable electricity like there's
things that you know you're going to
have to pay if that's on auto draft and
it's just taken out it actually helps
you not lose track uh it helps you not
be late uh all that so making sure you
have that buffer though so you don't
overdraft on your account that you have
the money for it is a great option we do
that too where we can just because it's
convenient it's nice to just have it
paid when you know you have to pay it so
I'm all for that Jason it's a great
question all right up next we have
Michelle in Green Bay Wisconsin hey
Michelle welcome to the show
hi Rachel thanks so much for taking my
call absolutely how can I help
so I have a question about saving and
paying for a wedding
um my fiance and I are both in baby step
two I'm wondering if we should pause
baby step two and pile up some cash flow
we can pay for a wedding and or
honeymoon or if we should just
um kind of keep going and try and do it
on the side or what you'd recommend yeah
it's a great question how much do each
of you have left in debt
I have about 10 000 he has about five
thousand okay so you guys are close to
the end of that how much do you make a
year
I make I'm 81 000 and he's 55 000. okay
and when's the wedding
oh we don't have a date set yeah we were
kind of trying to figure out budget and
how we were going to pay for it and let
that you know help guide us okay okay I
hear you uh how long have you been
engaged
since July so almost a year oh yeah so
you're ready I mean yeah you're ready to
get married I get that
um you know what I would do when it
comes to this kind of thing uh doing
both at the same time I think is it is
ideal because you guys are going to want
a wedding and a honeymoon but I think
you have to be realistic to say okay our
budgets for the wedding and honeymoon is
not going to be astronomical it's not
going to be huge because we have other
things in our life financially we're
taken care of so having a realistic
expectation of the wedding and the
honeymoon is really important but I
wouldn't want to lose momentum when it
comes to paying off debt but you have
ten thousand left so I'm like Michelle
you could you could still do this if you
guys do a couple of side hustles and
bring in some extra cash you could have
this knocked out really quickly
yeah for sure for sure and we're on
track for that but we're both kind of
just feeling like man it'd be really
nice to just you know get married we're
anxious to get married so part of me
thought well maybe we could just pause
and um yeah you know and pile up some
cash for the wedding and we have a very
small budget we're probably gonna only
spend around five thousand so I think I
can get there quick yeah but then I
would say that up on the side and kind
of have a goal to say okay you know by
fall or whatever the date is right maybe
it's July whatever it is to say yeah we
want to be married by then uh we're
gonna save up some money on the side to
pay for and you may pay as you go
because vendors are going to want you
know maybe a deposit things like that so
keeping track of it and
um I don't have to tell you because I
know you said we have a small bunch and
all of that and we're all four weddings
and enjoying the celebration of marriage
and life and all the things but just
being realistic and you guys I mean
because the reality is you could just go
down to the courthouse and get a
document and be married tomorrow right I
mean like you you can go and get married
if you wanted to uh but I understand the
celebration but I just wouldn't I
wouldn't put it off getting married to
save up this crazy big budget for a
wedding and this is more for people
listening not necessarily Young Michelle
because I know you're you guys are you
have a small budget and you guys can hit
that pretty quickly but I think we get
caught up a lot when it comes to
weddings and honeymoons and expecting
very you know big and extravagant things
and we put off putting a decision like
marriage a really important lifelong
decision offer and events basically so I
just I want to make sure you guys the
priorities are kind of right in that in
your mind
yeah for sure for sure we both feel like
we've been to many of the big overdone
extravagant things and we just want to
keep it simple and you know and and just
celebrate but yeah yeah we don't want to
wait too too long so no and I think
that's great and I think you know the
big you know celebratory ones that
people spend a lot of money that's great
I mean I had a big wedding and you know
we're not against that but I think
putting it in perspective and
financially is really important and even
for the honeymoon Michelle too I would
say like yeah maybe you just plan a
three or four night getaway somewhere
that's less expensive and then at the
one year mark of your anniversary that
you guys are like oh yeah we're
completely debt free we have all this
money saved because we're combining our
incomes and we are living the debt-free
life and you guys go and and take a
great honeymoon you know that could be
an option too sure so I guess we have
one more one more layer to the question
our parents have gifted us some cash and
they said we can use it for whatever
we'd like
um we had kind of decided we were going
to save it for a potential down payment
on the house okay I think it'd be better
to fit 13 000 is the total oh nice and
they've given that to you guys with no
strings attached
correct they say it's up to you you can
do whatever you'd like you can use it
for a wedding because it's your parents
or you can use it for a house your
parents his parents
yes both of them both of them together
oh that's what yeah that's great okay
gosh Michelle if I were you I would take
5 000 of that
and then I would yeah I would take five
thousand of that and
pay have that for a wedding fund over
there I would take the rest of that 8
000 put it at the ten thousand of yours
or no I'm sorry I would knock out well I
want y'all married first before you
combine accounts right I don't want you
guys paying on each other's debts so
even if you split your parents money
which sounds so tedious but I would kind
of still run in those Lanes
um but put some money towards your debt
his debts depending on the amount of
money each parent gave and yeah I would
use that money now all that to say I
would use it for the wedding and I would
use it to pay off this debt because then
you guys can use your income to save up
for a down payment later down the road
but I would take care of the present
problems which is debt first and saving
up for the wedding and having that
budget so that's a gift for sure
Michelle I would use that today for the
things that you guys have that's a great
question well thank you guys so much uh
for calling and thank you for listening
America thank you to all the guys in the
booth thank you America for listening
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]